Think, yeah, yeah, we should get started.
Right, so we can start with the meeting. So thank you so much, President and Kari, for joining the call. Before we start off with the agenda for today, let me just give you a quick update that the training is scheduled for all four engineers. It will start from tomorrow between 3 to 4 Eastern.
And like we discussed, we have Paxton and Jimmy to appear for the live sessions and Jasp and one should go through the recordings.
Kip.
Hey, so tomorrow between 2:00 and 3:00 now.
3 to 4 Eastern.
Three to four, uh, yeah, Paxton and Jess gonna participate on that meeting, right?
Paxton and Jimmy.
G.
Jimmy, got you.
Okay, do you have it in your plan for him?
Yes, and I am accordingly for everyone else to see as well.
Yeah, yep, and I believe this will not be included in their lunch hours regarding.
No, no, they're separate, separate from the line showers, yes.
Thank you so much.
Okay, um, yeah.
OK, and it based on the priority that Arkadi gave you for the training site, right?
Yeah, the high impact issues will be covered first and then medium and then low.
Okay, and if you want to stage that training in the first stage, or say if you want to have a milestone for the first part, when is that milestone and what we should expect to have on that milestone?
I would say, I would say...
I'm sorry, so by milestone I think you meant the high impact issues by what time?
No, no, yeah, I mean, I mean, if the course takes a month to handle, we should wait for a month to see the result of that course, or we do have another milestone before the course ended and see, okay,
After 10 days, we should expect to have all the these subjects to make sure that all those subjects handled and trained by your training to ours to the technicians. This is the reason why I ask is we can.
set our expectation to the end of the training part or we can have some milestone during the training session.
Yeah, so this I need to check with the trainer because, like I said, they would first give them the technical concept and then let them do the hands-on. So, as per my understanding and opinion, first...
when a certain topic is covered, they would go through the hands on for that particular topic and so on, rather than covering topics belonging to a certain technology 1st and then going through hands on. So this is something I need to check with the trainer. I'll give you an update by the end of day today.
Yeah, or if you have a curriculum of the course that they want to have, they want to like train on, it would be beneficial for us to say, okay, after 10 days, five days, after a week, we should see.
Have these these skill set improved in our our technician, and then we can see the effect of that in our side, as Arkadi can clearly say, OK, yeah, I see the improvement in this side and that side because of that training, and it would be.
The win-win project for you and us, I think.
Yeah, yep. So, suppose, you know, if if I proceed with like covering topics from a certain technology, this is covered, engineer has the hands on, I'll give you the update. So, would you then start giving them tickets from that technology, or would you assist them first and then?
Gradually, you give tickets from that technology.
I think those are not new technology that we expect them to handle the ticket. It's the day-to-day stuff and they already work on those tickets, but we can see the improvement. Yeah, like if I'm not sure about the first.
Yeah, I mean, the concept, yeah.
the first primary topics that they have. If it is about Active Directory stuff, we should see the improvement for them to how to handle the Active Directory new user creation. Or if it is about SharePoint, definitely Arkadi can have, give them some tickets about that.
Watch them to how to handle this stuff, and then give you feedback about the training part.
Okay, let me just quickly bring up the topics that we have for the training so that we all can.
Go through it once again.
Right, so these are the topics that I hope must be invisible.
Yeah.
Okay, so starting with the high impact topics first, NTFS permission, I think this is something that we need to pressure on.
Uhh...
Sign in, audit logs, again, refresher.
device identification, pressure, understanding of licensing is something that they need to go through.
I also noticed there was FX logic as well that was mentioned somewhere. So that is something that we need to be trained on thoroughly. There it is.
Okay, so we will share the milestones, Razdan, as you have mentioned, and we'll see it from there.
And Ashish, just to add one more thing over here, probably while we are coordinating with the training team, we can get the number of hours, which it's going to spend on that particular topic and the post, awesome, thank you, and the post assessment scores.
That has been shared already.
Okay, yeah, it's good. Yeah, once you once you have the lesson plan for from from the from the trainer, it's good to share with us. Then, based on the lesson plan, we can say tomorrow the lesson plan is this, this, this.
And.
And by the end of this week, we have that lesson plan. They're gonna, yeah, they already studied that part and that part. So then Arkadi can work on it. Yeah.
the progress bar, how many topics have been completed and how many are left out.
Kip.
Thank you.
Sure, I'll make sure this is done.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
Welcome.
Right, before I jump into the presentation deck, anything, Razdan, you want to share about the engineers?
Enough.
Go ahead, Arkadi.
Well, there was another issue yesterday with Vanj where he took a ticket that was an immediate offboarding for a user that was already assigned to Jimmy, actually, whose shift continues until 8 P.m.
I.
So he was expected to do the onboarding. So Vanch did send out the request for approval. That was correct. But there is no reason for him to take that ticket and keep it when his shift was about to end. So he basically...
If we didn't spot this, he would have left us in a position where if the user or the approver replied saying, yes, proceed, nobody would have seen this. So we would have been left without.
action in this immediate onboarding or even knowing that it was actually approved, right? So I don't understand why he was so eager to jump on a ticket that was already assigned to another technician and grab it for himself and then send out the reply and then keep it in his own queue.
what his shift was ending. That doesn't make any sense to me. So again, it created the possibility where a client would be coming to us with uncomfortable questions we couldn't answer. So.
Yeah, let me put it in this way, because Arkadi typically try to explain the possibility in a nice way. I would say, is there any communication outside of our process there between the technician that will work together?
Because you know, we don't have that process to pass ticket between technician without informing the team lead. And it happened there. The ticket passed from, the ticket passed from Jimmy to Ranch or Ranch to Jimmy, or there was a communication on the outside of our process.
Yeah.
I.
Between them that jumped on a ticket and grabbed that ticket and communicated with the user, this is the this is my understanding from that ticket, if I'm not mistaken on that, okay.
If I may, if I may clarify, the ticket, so Aston was on triage. He assigned the ticket to Jimmy, to go to the action, but Jimmy, Vanch on his own accord, went in and took it after that, assigned it to himself, sent a reply to the client, and then just kept it.
Yep.
Right, so he interfered with the triage process, with the intended process, in a way that didn't make any sense, right? There, as I understand, there is no communication between Jimmy and Vanch, because...
Yeah.
There would be no reason to have that, right?
It just did that the whole situation doesn't make any sense to me why that why he decided to do that.
And it all happened yesterday, Arkadi?
Yes, right before 5, like within 10 minutes before 5 o'clock.
May I get the ticket number so that I can view it?
Let me find it again.
And it's on everything is okay if they want to grab ticket and handle it. But we say we need end-to-end process, which means if you grab the ticket, take the responsibility of that, go to the end of the ticket, handle it. Or you want to do some part of that, it's totally fine.
I do appreciate that you step in and I want to help, but leave it as is without informing anyone and for the time sensitive stuff, because end of the employment is a time sensitive for our client. They say, okay, go ahead and do urgent EOE.
right after 5 means at 5 we should do that. Even for one minute, even one minute, 10 minutes for them is important. And the Arkadi, yeah, I think we were lucky to catch it. We were lucky.
Yes, yes, it was pure, pure luck, yes.
The.
Okay.
Thank you so much, Khattri Razdan, for sharing it. Anything else from the last week that you want to share?
Yeah.
Just seeing good progress from Jimmy and Paxton. Jasper is always great on the phones. So happy, reasonably happy with those three. As always, it's a process. It's always a continual improvement, but reasonably happy with those three so far.
Yep.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Just add that unpleasant surprise with Dan yesterday.
Yeah, OK. Well, I apologize for that. I will work with the once and share my findings.
Kip.
Thank you.
Okay. Hi, Keith.
Yeah, Ashish, hey everyone. Sorry for joining late. My last call got overflowed.
And.
Noise.
All right, so gentlemen, Keith is working with ITBD by design as a senior technical team lead. So he will be a part of the service calls moving forward and will be helping us with the overall management of the partnership. Yeah, welcome, Keith.
QA.
It.
Nice to meet you.
Thank you. Looking same here. Look forward to work with you guys. Thank you.
Nice to meet you, Kevin.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Rick.
So let me quickly bring up my screen. We can collectively go through the data for the ingenious from the past week.
Do you see it?
Mmh.
Yeah.
Okay, so first we have form and spotlight for lunch. So in the week of June, the first week of June, where we have received 3 surveys for lunch, this I got from a report that is being shared by Jeremy, where I got these three surveys which were positive for him.
Cases that I have written here, 2405963 and 2400468, these tickets had positive comments for a bunch.
where end users were satisfied with how Vansh dealt with the entire ticket. With the work distribution, so Vansh had 19 tickets triaged in the last week. Seven tickets were either facing issues, 16 of them were access application and system management, and 23 of them were.
installation setup and onboarding.
And he did answer 6 calls in the last week.
So, as you said, Reza, this is how you want his work distribution to be depicted, where we have percentage and number of tickets against this category.
Yeah, but again, user facing issue, it's not a category because problem resolution, access application or system, I would say 99% of the ticket that we have in Helpdesk is user facing. They don't handle any alert, they don't handle any...
I.
proactive maintenance or something like that. So we would say everything is client facing. So if you want to categorize it, I would give you the better categorization for the ticket to you. Then you can use those like say we can categorize based on the Mac request. How many Mac requests?
technician handled, which is important, including the onboarding, including offboarding, including service installation or something like that. How many, and then we do have another category which is incident, and under incident, we should categorize those, like say how many.
Yeah.
P1.
Sorry, how many P3, P4, sometimes P2 they handle? It is important part for us. Because incident is incident. When incident happens, it doesn't seem to matter what type of incident it is. The priority is important for us.
Kip.
And then based on that, we can say how efficient that technician is. So I want to ask Arkadi to share those information with you in terms of the incident and the categorization. And everything is in ConnectWise.
Mhm.
Yeah, I would appreciate it.
You have access to that. You can get all those information from there and give us those things based on those categories.
Yep.
Thank you so much, Rosa. So the access piece is still, which I don't have to connect wise manage. I am dependent on Engineering, their availability to connect to the machines and then get visibility to their data.
I.
Ohh.
I see, okay.
Go.
Any other questions on this one?
So overall, it's good having the category, knowing how many of ticket handles in which category is perfect to see the progress of stuff.
S.
Yep.
Thank you.
Next we have is for JASP. So for JASP, we have 5 positive surveys in the last week, out of which one survey was negative. So the overall rating that we have is 84% for JASP the last week. And this is from, again, from the report that I received from
Jeremy, this is not on the ticket with respect to the connect wise managed tickets. So from tickets, I have a separate category where I have different ticket numbers. This is on the basis of my board reviews for Jasp and revisiting the ticket that he closed in the past and see if those tickets were retained positively by the end user or not.
In work distribution.
Sorry, sorry, is this saying that he, that 60% of his work was triaged? That seems...
Inaccurate.
Yep, for the last week, for the last week.
That can't be right.
Yeah.
Sorry, that, that, that, yeah.
Maybe, maybe I could a day, cousin of it's not 60% of all this stuff. It might be a day or two days, right?
Jasper's on triage only in the morning as a backup to Ashley and then yes, two days of the week for half days. Two half days. Yeah.
Yeah, perhaps.
So 60% means half of a week, more than half of a week.
Yeah.
Yeah, double check those numbers. Yeah.
I will, I will check it, yeah.
And Ash, just for the clarity purpose, are you pulling this information from the reports which is being shared by the MSP comp team or from directly from the engineer?
Thank you.
No, no, no, no, no, no, this is not from the report. This is from their weekly time sheets.
Okay.
But I will double-check.
Mhm.
Maybe they count the merge ticket, cancel ticket. Is it viable? Yeah, it's likely that they count those. If you want us, Ashish, to compare the numbers and the way that you calculate those numbers, yeah, we can meet. You can schedule a meeting with Arkadi, go through the system, check one by one.
S.
because accuracy important in your side and we don't expect that you discover stuff in our side. We can give you some information to make sure that we all using the same numbers.
Yep, yep, and on top of this, you know, if I would have limited access to the Connect Voice Management tool, that would be a cherry on the top of the cake, because I have to investigate everything in a limited amount of time. So, if I would, if I would have access, I can sit back and go through everything in detail.
Mhm.
Rather than asking engineers to, you know, share the screen with me or share the monitor where I can get onto the computer and do this analysis.
Yeah, I think it's out of our control. We should speak with MSP Kour.
Okay.
I understand, yeah.
If not providing an additional license, just a suggestion, can any of the engineers, any of the senior engineers in the team, can we rather, can you guys provide the engineer the access to export tickets? So that by the end of the week, they can export a quick chunk of tickets that they get.
they worked on and shared it with Ashish.
There are two considerations here. The first one is all the access that all of the technicians have. We have is designed by MSP Corp team. We do have another team in MSP Corp. They manage everything, so I'm not sure about that.
Mhm.
The specific option that you want, and the second part is about the about the privacy of those information. I was, I'm not sure what's in the privacy, so you can double check it with.
Yes.
MSP core team, and because you know, if you want to use those information to analyze some stuff, definitely they should know about that, because you know, when when we have a technician based on some contract, technician has access to some data, but if...
Mhm.
Of course.
If you get export from data and analyze it and use it for another purpose, it's not only for, I know you want to use it for some numbers here, but having you exported data, it includes all the information for client, but...
Mm.
The issue they had, and some some business data might you need might might you need permission to use those, so double check those with MSP Kour, and if they wanna give you access to, definitely they can give you a separate access to.
Right.
Sure.
To to to get export sync data, even reports or something like that.
Mhm.
True, I mean the data would be way more meaningful for you guys as well. Like on the previous slide you mentioned, categorizing it based on MACD incident and then service requests as well. That'll be, that's a more meaningful data, of course, you had a point there. But yeah, that'll be super easy if we have the access or the export or the access to the tickets. It'll be super easy in that case.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. But as I said, performance spotlight that you mentioned here is okay for checking the technician performance. But we are in the process of preparing our KPI for each technician. So
Mm.
It mostly useful for your site to have those numbers. Might moving forward, once we have those KPI, we can share those KPIs with you and say, okay, these are the numbers that we assess and the performance trend for this technician is this and that. So
Then you don't need to deep dive to those all those information, find the numbers, put everything together. I know it's hard when you want to have when you have no full access to those data, but it's in it's in a plan. So once we have those, I think we can minimize our.
meeting and our exposure would be to just rely on those information that we have and then say, okay, this point needs to, needs more pay attention or this point is good as Arkadi mentioned like there.
And, in terms of phone call, say, Jasper's one of the one of the technician who handles the phone call, Jimmy as well, Paxton as well, so I think, yeah, yeah, well, well, we will we will have access to those data, so...
Got it.
So, in this case, I can skip the data for Jimmy and Maxon, because obviously it makes more sense in his situations. So, let me just unshare my screen. In this case, we are also...
about to complete the time that we have for this meeting scheduled. So another thing that I would rely is the CSAT survey. So Reza, thank you so much for sharing the feedback for Jazz. I know it's expanding for lunch. So when you get time, please share that as well.
At the same time, like you said, the milestones piece that you need visibility to, so I will get in touch with the trainer and share that with you on the required information. And yeah, I guess this is it. Do you have any other questions or suggestions?
Kip.
Rick.
31.
Nothing from my end. Thank you. Thank you, Ashish.
No, I'm good.
Thank you.
All right, so I'll meet next week. Until then, take care of yourself. Have a good one.
I.
Bye.